[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
um
[Music]
hi everyone good evening and welcome to
the table
my name is karen miner and i'm part of
the leadership team
at the table it's been a while since
i've been on this side of the screen
so i'm just really happy to be back and
it's good to be with all of you um can
you do me a favor
if you are watching uh please comment
down below let us know who you are
and uh let us know that you're here so
we can welcome you personally
um i just have one announcement tonight
before we get started did you know that
the table has a book club
and it meets every month it is led by
the amazing
sarah johns and glenda bayeron and
[Music]
this group is great it is good for
anybody that likes to read or even if
you're like me
i have really good intentions of reading
the book each month sometimes i get
through it sometimes i don't
but i love showing up and just having a
great conversation
with people um it's really a bright spot
uh in the month especially as we
continue on with
uh covet and quarantine and all of that
so if you are interested in uh being a
part of the book club
we do have a book selection for the
month of november it looks
great it's a novel called afterlife
yes afterlife by julia alvarez and
uh if you are interested in learning
more about the book club
and learning when it's meeting this
month and where
um if you could click on the link um
marissa is going to put that in the
comments for us uh if you're interested
in hearing more about that meetup just
click on the link put in your
information
click that you're interested in the book
club and we will have somebody get back
to you with more information
we'd love to have you be a part of that
so
um you picked a great night
to be here at the table this is a
special edition service
we are having a panel discussion with
three members from our table community
and we're going to be reflecting back on
our recent series
about just processing dealing with uh
difficult scriptures that are in the
bible so it's going to be good and i'm
so glad you're here
and before we dive into worship with
mindy and melody and maggie uh
i thought we could pray so would you
close your eyes and bow your heads with
me
god thank you for tonight thank you for
another week
together again god i pray blessings
of peace and grace over everyone that is
watching
i pray that they would feel encouraged
and connected and not alone and
god we take this moment to center on you
again and to remember who you are that
you are good
that you are love and that you are for
us
and god i pray that you would
open our eyes and our minds tonight
continue to expand
our awareness of who you are
of your character and of just how you
orchestrate in our lives
god help us to say yes to you whatever
that looks like for each one of us
help us to take that next step towards
you and
just pray that you would speak to us
tonight through worship through the
message
and the panel discussion and
that we would remember god who you are
and that we are yours
in jesus name amen
hello table family hey guys
um we're really excited to be with y'all
tonight we are actually coming to you
from
glorietta new mexico yeah um we got to
take a quick
sister's trip um with our youngest kids
up here
to visit our brother micah and his wife
karen and
it's just been some really great family
time with them
and um now we're getting to spend some
time doing some worship together and i
hope that
it provides a space for you guys to just
feel at home to feel that in the
creativity of music
you find some groundedness and some
peace
i um i love
that in worship i feel like no matter
where i'm at or what i bring
that i experience the presence of jesus
there
and um there's no qualifiers for how i
have to come
i just bring what i have so i hope that
you'll do the same
and um worship with us as you
as you are able to
when the music fades
and all this stripped away
[Music]
that will
is
[Music]
things
and it's all about you
it's all about you jesus
i'm sorry
[Music]
is
and it's all about
[Music]
jesus i'm sorry lord for the
thing
[Music]
is
i'll bring you more
[Music]
oh
be
[Music]
is
upon
[Music]
in
it
[Music]
z
is he
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
we
[Music]
yes
i'm
[Music]
to is
oh jesus
[Music]
oh
jesus
[Music]
the sun
[Applause]
[Music]
i
jesus thank you that you are god
over all things over all people
that you can be found by all people
of all religions and all races
[Music]
thank you god that we find you in all
places
here in the mountains and at home
you are not far from us you are close
and you are present and you don't hide
yourself away
we love you we love being with you
god stay close to us and help us to stay
close to you so that we
can share the love and light and life
of jesus with this world it's in your
name i pray
amen good to be with you guys
thank you ladies it was awesome awesome
awesome
well good evening everyone grace and
peace
welcome to the table and i'm really glad
that you all could be with us so
the series we just wrapped up uh last
week was titled scripture
dealing with difficult texts and uh it
covered you know a lot of
ground we kind of i mean really we
touched on
on just many many of the thorny issues
in the bible
you know from you know verses that sound
right just kind of downright homophobic
um two passages where
um god seems to kind of promote um
violence
to um i mean hellfire and damnation
you know the uh passages that kind of
seemed to mean women
um even the question of whether the
bible is against
people from you know non-christian
religious traditions so
like i said a big series and it was one
that proved to be
um in many ways very pivotal uh for
us like in in ways that i didn't um
foresee
because it ended up being kind of a
chance for us to kind of name
some of the um kind of the approaches to
christian theology
that make the the table as a church
community a little bit different like
of course in the essentials we're just
like normal christians right we believe
jesus
is um the son of god that he died on the
cross to forgive sins that through his
you know resurrection
um sin and law and death and suffering
and violence are all
overcome and conquered and that because
of that we get to to live you know a new
life
so like in all those senses we're just
you know
regular christians um but in some of
these i'll call them kind of the
non-essentials you know like places
where christians kind of
can disagree but still all be considered
christian like in all those areas not
all but many of them um you know we we
kind of landed
in some different places than than many
um of our other brothers and sisters in
the faith so
um that was kind of you know this series
was a chance for us to to flush some of
that out
so one practice that we really want to
encourage here at the table
is is that of um reflection that's not
something we
do a lot in our culture we're very fast
moving and so we like have an experience
and we move on
um but you know if if you've ever had
though like
just a significant experience it can
really help
to take kind of inventory of you know
what happened
um to reflect on it you know process it
allow it to kind of sink
in so uh although you know we don't do
this like after every series we did
think
uh that it would be wise tonight to go
ahead and as karen mentioned we're gonna
have a panel discussion
uh just to kind of allow all of us um
some of this the space to
to do this now uh for those who maybe
you've missed the series or at least you
know many of the messages no worries um
you'll you should still be able to
pretty much follow along tonight
since we have some some really wonderful
people
who will be sharing some of their own
stories what they
gleaned from the series you know things
that kind of made them think or or
see christian faith or christ in a new
light
so they'll be kind of processing um with
us
and uh and they are there at least uh
one of the faces um you'll probably
recognize since um
she did a reading for us a few weeks
back but there'll be a few new faces
it's funny because
um all of these folks have really joined
us
you know since the pandemic which means
they've never
um like attended a an in-person service
at the table granted
we only met for like four and a half
months before the pandemic so
there's actually a number of folks who i
don't you can't even really say like oh
so they're new
uh i don't know are they still new i
mean it's been you know like for many of
them three months
five months six months eight months like
it's been
it's been a while so i don't know if
they're new so much as they just haven't
maybe been face to face you've probably
seen their name show up in the comments
section you know
on facebook or something um during our
services and such but uh anyway so all
right
so with that in mind let me go ahead and
let's bring our panelists
on out here uh so uh
these are are all folks if you're
wondering like well what why did they
get chosen
well i mean a because they're awesome
but b
because um at some point each of them um
kind of reach out to me during the
series uh like just via text or email or
you know just in some way just naming
that they were impacted
um and so you know kind of
full disclosure if you're gonna do that
which is awesome i i encourage you to do
it
you might get asked to be on a panel so
that's kind of
that's part of it of course i could have
said no and they didn't they said yes so
uh thank you all uh for being with us
tonight
um and and also i wanna name these
they're also people i just i trust their
voices you know i
um i've met with each of them you know
one-on-one
um kind of outdoors at a at a coffee
shop
so uh so i i feel like i have some you
know relational capacity with them and
and know them and i wanted you all to be
able to meet them so um all right
welcome y'all so glad you could view
with me tonight
um so we're gonna um just start by
having
you guys um go ahead and just introduce
yourselves you know just
all the things name where you live how
you found the table
all that so eric how about you go ahead
and
kick us off hi i'm eric nichols
i live in frisco i found the table
through
marissa met brett in person and
after a couple sermons i was uh
pleasantly surprised at uh the services
at the table
and how it made me feel closer to god
yeah that's that's awesome you said
pleasantly surprised
what what was kind of your expectation
i didn't really have an expectation um
growing up
in the southern baptist religion um
church was usually a hateful place so
pleasantly surprised gotcha yeah and
you'll probably have a chance to share a
little bit of your experience with some
of that background later on so
um all right thank you eric stephanie
you want to go next sure i'm stephanie
um thank you first of all for inviting
me to participate
i'm pretty new to the dallas area i
moved here about a year and a half ago
i spent a little over a year in
richardson and i'm a new
allen resident before that i lived in
the hill country outside of austin
and i actually found the way to the
table
through marissa also so marissa this is
your night
um but it was actually through a meet-up
group at a dog park
and so it was it was just completely
unfaith related but that did lead to
another group
and she posted uh the online services
here
and i've been here ever since
that's greatness cody
hi good evening table um my name is cody
jacobs
i live in plano texas um
i grew up in the area i'm really from
rockwall texas
but um here recently i you know i was
looking for a more
vibrantly inclusive church and i
actually
found the table online
the week after uh you guys last in
person sermon
and service and so i missed you guys by
a week
but um i've been following you guys ever
since um watching the
services i've just really been enjoying
it
well we are glad to have you and uh
and like i mentioned all three of you
really glad to have you so um
all right let's let's kind of jump in
tonight so obviously you know in this
series
we um like i mentioned we covered a lot
of ground lots of topics
um but of course kind of lurking behind
um kind of all of those um what we call
difficult texts
uh was really the the question of how we
how we
read how we think of you know the bible
our kind of view of the bible itself
so this was kind of a two-part question
but could you start by
just sharing a little bit about um kind
of your own religious upbringing
um you know how that tradition of
christian faith kind of thought of the
bible
how that you know worked for you if you
loved it if you were like
not sure you know um that's a little bit
of kind of background on your own
approach the bible and the tradition you
were you were raised in
so i was raised
strict southern baptist in a family that
if the church doors were unlocked we
were there
for everything um
i hated going to church it was always
hellfire and damnation
um later in life uh
being told that i was an abomination
uh that i would be excluded from the
kingdom of heaven
things like that really turned me away
from religion
gotcha so pretty intense even in your
intro you kind of mentioned
it was a and it sounds like um i mean i
was trained by southern baptist so i
know
you know even within the southern
baptist kind of tradition there's
kind of varying levels of intensity it
sounds like you're coming from a pretty
um i mean like you mentioned kind of a
hellfire damnation
um kind of wing even of that
that tradition so um pretty
um yeah pretty difficult yes
connection yeah yeah um
all right anyone else want to jump in
well um
surprisingly um i can relate to eric a
lot
because i too grew up southern baptists
but we were kind of like a pecos church
you know we still spoke in tongues
you know we had the lively services
but it was very straight um um
hell and damnation was taught a lot and
so it really
had me growing up in fear you know um
very
scared to do anything wrong anytime i
did wrong i would just pray
for like 30 minutes speaking the times
like forgive me forgive me
and so that was my opinion then it
really did affect me when i became
an adult uh going through my own issues
and only people could tell me was you
know you're an abomination
you know you have to repent and live
wholly and be sanctified
that's that was pretty much my whole
background
yeah yeah um how about um
what would you say is kind of like when
you think of the bible and how the
the bible was kind of used and this is
maybe for both cody and eric and then
stephanie you of course can jump in
any time but how would you say those
traditions kind of
you know thought of the bible um
how yeah how did it how did the
scriptures kind of
function or or work in the the community
um does that does that question make
sense
yeah um
the church i went to was
the scripture was the word that there
was no
interpreting it it's just a literal
reading um
and that was the word of god that's how
you had to live your life
yeah yeah yeah yeah
there was no um trying to research this
scripture or study the scripture it was
that's what we're saying in black and
white that's what you go by
but there is no way around it if you try
to go around it then you know you're
trying to twist god's word
and so what he said is that's pretty
much how you live
yeah so i had a really different
experience
my upbringing included several
denominations
baptist evangelical
presbyterian and i don't i didn't
experience what
what you both experienced
the church was sort of like the social
group that we hung out with i went to
sunday school
youth people hung out on the holidays
um the bible was something that we
studied and it was explained to us
[Music]
it was pretty pretty low key for me
yeah so it sounds like um
yeah like you said kind of low key so it
was the bible is there it's a part of
our kind of life
and as as a person of faith and in the
church
but it wasn't necessarily kind of uh in
your face
almost aggressive the way cody
and eric's are kind of describing their
experience is that
i would say that but i was
it i wasn't doing anything that they
didn't the scriptures and
and the the community didn't think i
should be doing so
um it was easier
yeah like you were kind of in in line
with it so like hey don't
don't come after me for anything like
yeah gotcha
um how so kind of thinking back on this
series
um i had kind of these two big ideas
when it came to this id
the the question of scripture and just
how we think of it interpret it
um and so the two ideas were basically
number one the point of scripture is to
point to jesus
and then second i said we need to read
the bible or interpret the bible through
the lens of love
so those were kind of two big guiding
ideas um
and i i kind of wondered like those two
insights was that something like you're
familiar with were those kind of a new
way of approaching the bible
you know and depending on that answer
did that resonate with you
was it kind of weird like how i'm
wondering how that
those ideas of you know kind of the
scriptures pointing to jesus
that's the whole point of them and this
idea of the lens of love interpreted the
lens of love
um how does that how did that kind of
strike you um
i
i loved it i mean imagery of it pointing
to jesus that was
it for me it diffused some of the
tension around
what version do you use is it you know
literal it just made a lot of sense and
it connected a lot of struggles that i
had as a younger adult
that said well if i don't follow these
rules
that the catholic church teaches me
because i became catholic
you know am i going to hell am i leading
people astray
but if i do follow these rules i'm not
loving these people and accepting them
so that was a real problem for me so
having it as point to jesus
and reading through a lens of love that
was awesome
yeah cool cody or eric how about for you
so a lot of times they
forget um i'm sorry
i think a lot for me a lot of churches
they forget
about jesus and they focus more on their
denominations and their own teachings
and so you know of course the first
point is to
point to jesus but then when you're
trying to teach
your own denomination your own beliefs
then and
jesus kind of goes out the picture
and the message about you know
seeing it through the lens of love i've
never heard that before so it really
touched me
because you know i just never heard that
in church before
you know we teach about love we teach
about the love of god but when it comes
to approaching
other people trying to reach the gospel
to them love kind of goes out the window
sometimes
yeah that's that's a remarkable thing
isn't it that
that the way it's so easy and
i wouldn't exclude the table from this
how we can get so focused on our
own kind of thing our own take on the
faith
our own theology that like jesus can
start to get kind of crowded out
and we start to maybe talk about him
less or
um that's just yeah that's a strange
a strange thing um but it is it's so
easy uh
yeah for that to happen and so what a i
think that is one upside maybe to that
approach is it it helps us to stay
centered
um you know kind of on him uh
eric i know you were jumping in uh
um so i like your word um looking at it
with a hermenetic of love
um i had to go look that up and study
that um
still having problems
processing that um reading difficult
text
and understanding
and changing it to reinterpret or
reinterpreting it so that
i'm looking at it through a lens of love
[Music]
but at least now i'm not completely
ignoring the old testament
um it's actually still there
yeah so for you it's kind of um well a
you mentioned
some of the struggle of like it's kind
of a it's a challenge a little bit like
a mental
like okay this is a fresh take which i'd
like you to unpack a little more but
also
you mentioned it kind of has helped you
connect with parts of the bible again
which is really interesting because i
wonder if folks might if they're hearing
my messages they might get really
nervous like
are you like people are gonna just read
the jesus parts or something
you know so um yeah you can jump on
either one of those or however you'd
like to but i'd be interested in your
thoughts on that
um so
you described uh that
some people's take on it was just to
ignore the old testament
um that's what i've always done um
ignore the old
the old testament because that's where
the bad stuff is
um all the stuff that scared kids you
know
in in church you shouldn't be scared of
church
um so that's really
i don't know it allows me to read the
old testament again
and understand that
maybe i can reinterpret
what what's actually being said
kind of putting it in context yeah
yeah that's beautiful how about uh
stephanie cody any other thoughts on
this before we
shift on
i don't have anything okay so the the
other um
or i should say the other but probably
the you know the kind of
hottest topic in the contemporary church
out of all of the messages we did
um really surrounded the passages that
um
can can sound quite um anti-gay
uh obviously you know at the table we're
an open and affirming
kind of church community but i'm
wondering
um you know what if anything you found
particularly helpful in that message
and then kind of how you how
how has that message kind of caused you
to go back and read the scriptures and
specifically those
passages you know has it changed
anything for you i mean it's possible
you'd already
kind of change some of your views
beforehand you know whatever but anyway
i'm just wondering
how did that message land um how did it
impact you
you know things along along that those
lines so
well for me it was definitely an
eye-opener it's still a process because
when you
grew up in church listening to the same
message
and believing in one thing it's really
hard to just change overnight
even though you know that it's right uh
i can tell
this that sermon really did touch me
because of what i deal with
you know being in the south and
the sermons that i heard regarding
homosexuality
it was also taught with toxic
masculinity as well
and so it was just pretty much preachers
not even wanting to
see the love of
gay christians um they you know use that
moment to
make fun of the gay community and
just people just really made people you
know uncomfortable
and concerned the fact that you know a
lot of people in the church were
straight
it was um it turned into maybe a comedy
fest
pretty much and i have so many
services i remember where people were
just killing themselves laughing
and while the pastor just making fun of
gay people and it really did
affect me because you know i am dealing
with it as an adult
and i tried to talk to pastors to pass
about it
and there was no help it was just
that's wrong you know there is no way
that you can
serve christ and live like that and you
need to change you need to repent
and that was the only advice i've gotten
you know all these years
and it really caused depression and a
lot of mental issues
and so hearing that message from you
it really i really felt the love and i
really
you know the love of god
let me know that you are mine and you
are accepted
and yeah
so um as far as um the scriptures
i have studied i'm still i'm researching
because i say it doesn't happen
overnight
but i am definitely reading them through
a different lens now
and it's a lens of love
um i mean just hearing the
thinking back on pat sounded like you're
describing kind of past church services
like where you sat there and um
my goodness eric or stephanie have you
ever experienced anything
like that or or has your experience been
kind of different
definitely um yeah
i i don't know if it was really at at
least once a month but it seemed like
once a month there was always
some hateful message directed toward
gays
i even remember a pastor saying you
can't be gay and christian
it's just not possible
so yeah yeah
definitely the same for me
anything other than a man and a woman
post marriage vows was strictly
uh you know a ticket on the express bus
to
hellfire and damnation which i think
we're going to talk about later
but um not only that
it was i heard it called a disease
i i've watched people turned away
from churches um
and it doesn't fit with the verses that
we talked about with jesus coming to
save our people
uh it just it never made sense to me
yeah um i mean i i think and just even
reading some of the comments y'all
aren't alone
um you know and this
kind of some of these experiences it's
it is it's a huge
challenge and and and as even like cody
mentioned i think eric you might allude
to this as well like
you know and but it's okay to be in
process with those
texts right like we want space for
people at the table to be able to come
and wrestle with the bible
and you know do our best to interpret it
and read it through a lens of love but
that doesn't mean we're always going to
read everything the same way you know we
kind of all have to be on our own
journeys
it sounds like where there's some unity
though is we
we want to approach it with love in mind
you know we want to be sensitive to
people like this seems like a pretty
basic
you know um thing and um
boy i hope we can um yeah start to do
do better on that um any anything else
any other thoughts on this
um this topic before we keep moving
so another um one we just
like i said all the all the authority
issues in this series
so another one was um women and the
bible
and women and kind of in that message um
you know we we kind of unpacked the two
trajectories in the bible
uh that that and specifically the new
testament which is really
like where you see this um you kind of
have one trajectory
or one line of thinking that's quite
liberated and inclusive of women
and then and you know another that is um
not
and so i wondered um stephanie maybe you
could start us off just sharing a little
bit your own experience in the church
um you know as a woman like has this
was this an issue was it not how what's
been
kind of your your experience with all
this and then of course as that relates
to the bible
sure so i'll start with where i am today
which is
squarely in the women are
included in all parts of church i wasn't
always that way
i actually drank the kool-aid for a long
time because
i didn't know any better and that's what
everyone around me was telling me
so women did not have a part in most of
the churches i was in
my thought is that leadership
and groups that are doing service
can't really do a good job unless
they're comprised of the
community that they're serving and the
communities that they want to include
so if a church wants to include everyone
then everyone you know all that
diversity needs to be represented
in the church so sometimes maybe it's
not in a leadership position
because if you're a small church right
but
you know here i am with a good woman on
the panel
um so that's kind of my thought i
and i'll say that it does a lot of
damage to not have that or
at least it did to me i've i've always
been in a
minority as far as gender um
male dominated organization i'm in tech
and even within tech my
particular organization has admitted
they're doing a terrible job with
diversity especially with women um i
went to a military university
i was in the military so
i i think the damage that comes from
that kind of thing is
i actually used to pride myself on
minimizing
what i considered and what i was told
were female liability
characteristics so like my best friends
in university were
men because there were only 900 or out
of 990 people there only
women in my graduating class and even my
best friend
would it was like normal and i
accepted it as okay that they would tell
me i shouldn't be there
so that's my thought it's not good
we need women in leadership we need
everybody in leadership and then
being the face of our spiritual groups
yeah was was you mentioned um you're
kind of now in this place
you know when what was that process like
for you to get there i mean has that
been you know years in the making
months weeks you know what's been your
your kind of
experience with that it's funny you say
that um because
i'm gonna thank my mom she
said we have a family tradition going
back to her family of easter sunrise
service
and so she was visiting one year and
catholic churches don't do that
um i don't know if other people will do
it but the methodist church right across
from our house
did it and so she wanted to go and i
said okay i'll go with you
and it was beautiful i highly recommend
the tradition
to anyone it's really not that bad to
get up
super early but there was
there was a female minister and
i don't remember much else about the
message i do remember the sun coming up
behind her
but i do she made just one quick
oblique reference to not understanding
why women shouldn't be able to preach
and that's really only been at less than
five years
and it just lit a fire yeah
yeah wow how about um eric or cody
um you want to jump in with just any of
your
kind of what you've observed the i mean
obviously you've heard a little bit of
the traditions you've come from
um but although i don't totally know
uh for both of you maybe women were
included in those in terms of leadership
i'm not sure
how what was that like
for me women were not allowed
in leadership however toward the end
they were teaching sunday school classes
before that it was
always the deacons um the men of the
church
but i don't know now
where they stand i know there's
uh the church by my house there's women
in ministry in fact i think the whole
church
leadership is female which is great
so um the church i grew up in it
they have evolved so much and i'm so
happy for them because
even though i look very young and i'm
seeing so much happen
um when i was a kid the women
were not allowed in the pulpit but that
changed to okay they can be in a pulpit
but a woman can never
be a pastor you know a mummy pastor
that's just wrong
and i believe they have gone away from
that because they have invited other
churches to fellowship with them with
women pastors so
that's very exciting um to see but
there was a church that i was a part of
not too long ago a couple years ago
they're still stuck back in the day um
the women
are not even allowed on the front row
and i always thought that was kind of
weird
i went to church one of my female
friends one time and
we were walking and the usher was like i
have to separate you too
you're not married i need you on the
front row and she needs to sit a couple
rows behind you
and i was like okay i don't agree with
that you know we came here together but
um so there's still some churches that i
know that
you know are still stuck back in the day
but it is
wonderful to see a lot of churches
evolve over the years
to allow women you know that
hold the positions that they rightfully
deserve
yeah yeah it's a that's
an amazing story of even it's
interesting how even seating
arrangements
can be a very powerful way to
communicate
you know who's the priority
here and all sorts of
kind of verbal and nonverbal cues that
kind of indicate
um yeah what we what we think
you know and um and stephanie hearing
your story of that's such a powerful
image of you you said about five years
ago kind of going to this
this easter sunrise service and there's
like oh my gosh
female preacher you know and um
which is yeah that's pretty amazing and
how appropriate for easter since the
first preachers of the resurrection to
the disciples
we're the ladies so it
seems very appropriate so yeah
awesome um
so the another topic that we hit on was
that you know there are bible kind of
passages that describe god as
quite violent um and
some of what what we named was that that
tends to shape
kind of how we you know i use the
language of image god in other words
like how we
understand how we imagine or view um
you know god so i wondered could you
share a little bit about
how you image god growing up how that's
shifted through the years
you know perhaps um how if anything
intersected with this series in terms of
you know thinking through
those violent passages that kind of
intersects with the um the piece that
eric talked about earlier with the old
testament you know since a lot of these
are from the old testament
um so anyway yeah kind of walk us
through how do you image god how it's
changed
anything with the series that helped in
that regard we'd love to hear it
so for me
growing up
god was something to be feared
or a being to be feared um
he would strike you down if you send if
you
didn't try to live your life in his
image
to the point where i think until i was
10 years old
i would hide from lightning so i
couldn't be struck down
um so
[Music]
my image of god then was very different
than it is today
i've always questioned i believe that
god made me the way i am
if god made me this way why does he hate
me
why is he saying i can't go live with
him
in heaven never understood that
so i feel like maybe the baptist
southern baptist religion has that wrong
i hope so
um and that i'm not condemned to hell
stephanie cody how about you so um
for me it was um always an angry god
you know i heard more messages about god
being angry more than god
loving um and i got the point where
i use god as a defense you know somebody
did me wrong or he saw somebody doing
something bad it was
god's going to get him or get him god
you know
we use that as like you know attack
you know you know teach them a lesson
strike them down
because that was all the messages that
mostly i remember as a kid
was um guys watching you do anything
wrong you know you
know you're gonna be convicted of it and
so
yeah i always you know grew up believing
that god just is
angry spirit and we just have to fear
him
at every moment
yeah i definitely grew up with more fear
than love
focus um
it makes me think about what we teach
our kids
you know
that seems to be um i mean kind of a
a theme here is this idea of fear
um what like looking back on your own
experience
why do you think that image of god was
so
kind of centered and prioritized and
um why why where do you think that fear
where was it coming from or what was the
why behind it what
and your your experience from your
perspective
i believe it was because they were
trying to get us to you know
to live holy and sanctified and
only way you can live this sanctified
and pure life
is if you fear god that if you
best live at any moment or if you did
anything
um that was simple then you were
risking missing the rapture or going to
hell
and so if you um just believe that god
was just a spiritual god and he's just
watching
every step and you walked on eggshells
then you would scarcely make it into
heaven
and so that was mainly um why
for me
i wonder if it has to do with
children and the way they hear things
like what pieces they focus on
most at young ages um
you know if you think only in black and
white good and bad
i think maybe it doesn't take that much
discussion of the bad
for that to really just blossom
and take over
[Music]
yeah like it just kind of that's the
thing that jumps out
um even if maybe other things were
mentioned but still
it's like that's that's what sticks
uh yeah eric how about for you what are
your
thoughts on that um like cody said um
you fear god um always walking on
eggshells um you can't backslide
um god you're gonna go to hell
if you do um i think it was
the message was centered around fearing
god so that you wouldn't
backslide or sin or whatever
you know i have one other thing i think
sometimes you know we forget that the
leaders of churches and denominations
are humans and
they're trying to do a good job so you
know hopefully
most of them i like to believe that and
it's about
um i think it can sometimes be about
control as a way to
make sure that their job is getting done
yeah like they feel a sense of
responsibility to keep people in the
straight and narrow
and um
yeah so they they use kind of the
resources at their disposal
and and one of those is the the idea of
hell
um and well an angry god which then kind
of leads into
kind of our next question which is you
know around hell obviously those two
tend to be very you know connected god's
um upset very upset
and if you don't get on the straight and
narrow then
eventually you know you will um you know
burn in hell forever
um i i maybe y'all could speak a little
bit to
um how so that the message i preached on
hell the way i kind of
i didn't say like oh there is no hell um
because i mean jesus himself talks about
you know hell he uses the language of
gehenna um
which people could kind of quibble with
like maybe it's different than what we
imagine
but still if you read all the quotes
from jesus on it i mean he's like
describing you know some sort of
you know hell um how we understand that
so what i'd named though was to keep the
idea of the love of god central where a
lot of
of the church many i should say many
theologians down to the centuries
have kind of read um
hell as like the fires as the fires of
god's love
the image here being this isn't about
punishment and gotcha
but a kind of a purifying healing
process
which then leads into this broader idea
of
um you know people being saved even
people maybe that we would be surprised
like
perhaps even all people all creation
could be saved
um so that was kind of it was a big
message we covered a lot of ground i'm
wondering out of all that
um you know what stood out to you what
have you wrestled with and and
thought through um yeah we're just kind
of your mind been
on this maybe we could start with
stephanie i know this is like near and
dear to her heart
this was my favorite one this is what
probably got me on the panel
i i've read the bible at least i think
i've read a lot of it
um but when you preached on first
corinthians um
three verses you talked about i think
several verses
but the last one um talked about
whatever we've built our earthly journey
or house with you know whether it's gold
or
hey it'll get burned up if it's not gold
but we won't be we're all gonna it says
um i wrote it down
um may suffer loss but yet we'll be
saved
even though only as one escaping through
the flames
and that was just like
just amazing because i i wrestle with
this everybody i think
that's kind of gone through some of the
things that cody and eric and i have
discussed
wonder are we going to hell you know
what is hell
and to know that i'm going to be saved
like i think it's the first time i
really felt
like i really believed it
so thank you
it's same for me um it definitely
resonated
uh that's probably the one most
important thing i took
from this four part series was
um my vision of hell
probably isn't correct um
and i need to reread and make sure that
i understand and
what when she said it was almost like an
epiphany
um when you read that i was like wow
that's amazing all this time it's been
right there
but never knew it yeah
i'm still mind blown about that message
to be honest with you
um i've never heard it preached like
that before
um yeah i'm just a
um just like there's and it's been right
there in front of me the whole time
but it just i guess i've always had the
wrong interpretation of it
i remember i can remember messages on
hell where i would just be sitting in my
they're just cringing because it's just
so
scary and just they go into detail about
you know
being whipped by a scorpion and they
they
try this stuff and you just
jump in your chair and you um
walk out of their church in complete
silence it's like wow
and so i i still you know say
thank you for preaching that message
yeah you're so welcome
it's um i remember years ago i read c.s
lewis's book the great divorce
which i think was um one of the uh
resources i think i mentioned in that
message
um that's uh it's not about like it's
not a book about marriage and such but
it's it's really about heaven and hell
and the this chasm kind of between them
but um it's a beautiful book and it was
really the first one that got me
thinking like oh
so seeing hell as as an expression of
god's love
seeing it as a place where um
god wants people to return from
i never thought i just i just never
thought of it in those
terms um and it really
i mean i guess i had a similar
experience to each of you in terms of
that really got me thinking
like huh maybe the bible's more
complex and interesting than i thought
it was um
but it was helpful because he also
wasn't just throwing it out you know
like
um i mean jesus talks about it so it's
something we really need to grapple with
um
so i'm yeah i'm glad that was that one
resonated with with each of you um any
just closing
thoughts um input anything before we
kind of wrap up no pressure but if you'd
like anything it's still on your mind
you're like oh wait i need to say i
wanted to
name you know whatever anything to jump
enough
no i'm just thankful that uh i found the
table
amen man i just feel so
free in my faith for once you know
you know free in my love of christ it's
a really good feeling
and this church has helped me a lot with
that
well it's it's an honor to have you all
as part of us i'm so glad that that
folks
watching and listening can get to meet
you know each of you in the way that i
have
um over the past few months and it's
yeah it's
it's wonderful to have you so thank you
for taking time thank you for being
vulnerable
you know sharing some of your story kind
of opening up in a way to
people and putting it you know out
publicly online that's um
really generous on your part so thank
you for doing that
um and uh yeah let me go ahead i'll just
close with with
a prayer um lord jesus we
we are just grateful for um
the ways that you speak you're so
faithful uh
to lead us into truth and so i pray over
every person
um hearing my voice
god that they would be drawn into your
love
that they would um read the scriptures
in
fresh and um
honest in beautiful ways god ways that
that lead them to become more like
christ so may the table may we as a
church community be marked
by that god may we as individuals
be marked by that that kind of love god
that's that's who we want to be
so make us a thoughtful people inclusive
um people kind generous
god do that work in us name of jesus i
pray
amen
i've tried to understand but i can't
seem to
find my faith against the wind
falling short
so please be my strength
please
[Music]
is
please
[Music]
i breathe
you
[Music]
oh
keep bringing me
because
[Music]
thank you so much for joining us tonight
i
hope that the service and the panel
discussion
encouraged you and reminded you that
you're not alone
and if somebody came to mind as you were
watching tonight that
might also be encouraged by the panel
discussion
please feel free to share this share
our website thetabletx.org you can share
this recording on youtube or on facebook
um
yeah we'd love for more people to um
be a part of this community and uh
to just read the bible
and relate to people through the lens of
love
so as we close i wanted to mention just
a few things
first don't forget about our book club
that's happening later this month
if you were interested and want to hear
more about it there will be a link in
the comments that you could click
and put your name a way to get in
contact with you
and just note that you're interested in
the book club and we will get back to
you with more information on that
and secondly if you resonate with the
values
and the vision here at the table we
invite you to give online
to help our community to continue to
flourish our website
is www.thetabletx.org
and as you go into your week i wanted to
leave you with this benediction
you are a child of god this is true
on your best days and on your worst days
you were wonderfully and lovingly made
there is only one you and there is
nothing about you
that is a mistake
the world needs you being fully yourself
free and authentic so as you go into
your week ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted
just as you are and go
filled with god's holy spirit
and the desire to extend these same
gifts of grace
and divine love to everyone you come in
contact with
be blessed and we hope to see you back
here next week
bye
you